[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين رش النرجس
صراع اشمل مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وموسكو
تتهم واشنطن باثاره التوترات العالميه
[موسيقى]
طهران تنفي سقوطها قتل ايرانيين في الضربه
الاسرائيليه على دمشق وريفها وروسيا تعتبر
الغارات انتهاكا للقانون الدولي
انتهاء عمليات الانقاذ في تركيا باستثناء
قهرمان مرعش
ومنظمه اطباء بلا حدود تحذر من نقص
المساعدات في سوريا
والصين تحذر الولايات المتحده من عواقب
تصعيد الخلاف بشان ازمه المنطقه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه قال
منسق السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
ان روسيا تحاول انتاج صراع اشمل واوسع مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي من خلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه مضيفا ان الاتحاد لم يكن
مستعدا بالشكل الكافي عند بدء المعركه
روسيا تحاول تحويل المعركه مع اوكرانيا
الى حرب اشمل مع الغرب وعلى الدول
الاوروبيه تقاسم الاعباء الدفاعيه والدفاع
عن قيم ومبادئ الامم المتحده كما يجب
تطوير دور التكتل الدفاعي والسيبراني خلال
الفتره المقبله الى جانب التركيز على
تقديم المزيد من الذخائر لاوكرانيا
وشدد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بارل على ضروره تطوير دور
التكتل الدفاعي والسبراني
وخلال كلمه كلمه الله في مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن اكد ضروره زياده وتشريع المساعدات
العسكريه الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا
واضاف المسؤول الاوروبي انه يجب على دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان ترسل ما لديها من
الذخيره ولا تنتظر كي تشتري ذخائر جديده
لترسلها
وقالت انه على المدى المتوسط يجب زياده
قدره الانتاج الدفاعي الاوروبي شريطه ان
تكون هناك ذخائر كافيه لكافه الدول على حد
تعبيره
الى ميونخ حيث مراسله العربيه راغده بهنان
تتابع هذا المؤتمر رغد اهلا وسهلا بك
مجددا اخر ما خرج به مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
وهذا التصعيد سيد الموقف تماما راغده من
دون الحديث عن اي حل سياسي للحرف في
اوكرانيا
اهلا بك طالب يعني انتهى هذا المؤتمر قبل
قرابه الساعه من الان وغادر معظم
المشاركين ولكن بالفعل الاستنتاج الطاغي
هنا على انه عوضا عن حل ربما مساله واحده
ظهرت مشاكل اخرى اضافيه الان على المجتمع
الغربي ان يواجهها على راسها يعني الازمه
بين الصين والغرب وتحديدا بين بكين
وواشنطن كان هناك امل بان يكون لقاء وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي مع المسؤول الصيني هنا
يعني ياتي او يؤدي الى تخفيف هذا التوتر
ولكن على ما يبدو هذا اللقاء لم يخفف هذا
التوتر بل على العكس ربما زاده لانه سمعنا
من بلينك اليوم يقول يعني في مقابله ادلى
بها لاحدى وسالام الامريكيه بانه حذر بانه
هناك اشارات ان الصين ربما تستعد لمساعدات
عسكريه لاعطاء مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا وقال
بانه ابلغ المسؤول الصيني بانه هذا الامر
سيؤثر بشكل كبير سلبي على العلاقات
الثنائيه بين الصين المتحده ايضا يعني
هناك مصدر قلق اضافي للدول الغربيه فهمت
يوم امس من دبلوماسي غربي بانه العلاقه
العسكريه بين ايران وروسيا وهي علاقه
متزايده بحسب مقاله ايضا باتت الان تشكل
مصدر قلق رئيسي لهذه الدول الغربيه التي
الان تسعى لدفع ايران يعني لفك هذه
العلاقه العسكريه مع روسيا لذلك بالفعل
ربما يمكن القول بانه هذه الازمه الحرب
على اوكرانيا
ومتفرعاتها كانت هي يعني ما طغى على هذا
المؤتمر ولم يكن هناك اي يعني ربما حلول
طرحت ولكن مخاوف جديده تحدث عنها الزعماء
هنا وسمعنا من جوازات بوريا اليوم كلام
يعني صادقه جدا بانه اذا لم نسرع بارسال
الذخيره لاوكرانيا خلال الاسابيع المقبله
ونتوقف عن التباطؤ يعني ربما يعني نواجه
نهايه للحرب وفوز يعني ولم يقلها بهذا
المعنى ولكن قال بانه يجب ان لا اكثر وجه
انتقادات لادعه للدول الاوروبيه لانها قال
من خلال متابعتك للمواقف هل تم التوافق
اوروبي امريكي واضح من ان هذه الحرب يجب
ان تستمر اي ان تكن التكلفه ام لا بعض
الدول الاوروبيه تخشى التداعيات
الكلام ليس على استمرار الحرب ولكن الكلام
من جميع القاده الغربيين على ضروره الا
تفوز لا يفوز الرئيس بوتين بحربه يعني هم
يصرون ايضا على تكرار بانه هذه حرب فوت
بوتين
ويقولون بانه هذا ضمن طموحاته ما يسمونه
طموحات الامبرياليه لذلك يعني هناك اسرار
على استمرار هذا الدعم لكي لا تفوز روسيا
بهذه الحرب ولكي يعني تحقق اوكرانيا بعد
الانتصارات على الاقل لكي تتمكن من الجلوس
على طاوله الحوار بشروط يعني لا تكون فقط
شروط روسيا هذا ما تحدث به الرئيس الفرنسي
ميال مكروفي اليوم الاول للمؤتمر في
الواقع ولكن اليوم يعني كان ايضا كلام من
رئيسه حكومه استونيا هنا التي جلست معجزه
بارال في طاوله الحوار وتقول بانه علينا
الاستعداد لما بعد نهايه هذه الحرب وليس
يعني علينا الاستعداد بمعنى عسكريا كدول
اوروبيه لانه هذه يعني
ولا وانتهت الحرب في اوكرانيا فالمخاطر
علينا باقيه ومستمره في السنوات القادمه
شعبيا قيل وشاهدنا بعض الصور عن احتجاجات
شعبيه في عدد من المدن الالمانيه تطالب
المجتمعين في مؤتمر ميونخ بعدم ارسال اي
اسلحه جديده الى اوكرانيا الى اي مدى يعني
هذه التظاهرات كانت كبيره حجم هذه
التظاهرات
يعني هذه التظاهرات تخرج في كل مؤتمر دولي
يعني هي خرجت في قمه السبع التي استضافتها
المانيا قبل العام الماضي وايضا قبل بضعه
سنوات هي ترافق هذه يعني الاجتماعات بشكل
دائم ولكن المستشار الالماني الذي ايضا
تحدثي اليوم الاول هو كان يشرح ما يرى
بانه تردد المانيا ولكنه كان يقول نحن يجب
علينا ان نمشي بحسب يعني الاراده ربما
الشعبيه كان يلمح الى انه
يعني الشعب الذي انتخب هذه الحكومه هو يثق
بها قال بانه استطلاعات الراي تؤكد بانه
الشعب مازال يثق بنا وهو لا يرى ترددنا
هذا تردد بل يرى بانه اصرار على انه لا
نذهب وحيدين لا نكون الوحيدين لدينا نتصرف
بشكل احادي بارسال هذه الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا لذلك هناك ثقه لدى الحكومه على
الاقل بانه الشعب الالماني خلفها في ارسال
هذه الاسلحه بهذا القدر من ميونخ مراسله
العربيه راغده بهنان شكرا جزيلا لك راغده
على كل هذه المتابعه
من جهه اخرى قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان روسيا لا ترى اي انفتاح على مبادرات
السلام من جانب الغرب بخصوص اوكرانيا
واضاف ان تصريحات وكيله وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه للشؤون السياسيه فيكتوريا حول
اعتبار القرم هدفا
واشنطن تؤكد عمق الخلاف بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا مشددا على ان هذه
التصريحات تعكس دور واشنطن الرئيسي في
اثاره التوترات العالميه
تنتمي سيده نولاند الى مجموعه كبيره جدا
من الصقور الاكثر عدوانيه في السياسه
الامريكيه وتصريحاتها وجهه نظر معروفه
انها تؤكد مره اخرى عمق خلافاتنا ودور
الولايات المتحده كمحرض رئيسي للتوتر
الدولي القائم
معي من موسكو لمزيد من هذا الموضوع
المستشار السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه السيده ايلينا سوفنينا سيده
سابونينا اهلا وسهلا بك قبل ان اسالك عن
موقف السيده فيكتوريا نولاند ورد السيد
ديميتري بيسكوف بدايه كيف تقرئين المواقف
التي خرج بها مؤتمر ميونخ وهي مواقف عاليه
السقف بكل المعايير واي مرحله ستدشنها هذه
المواقف في الحرب الجاريه في اوكرانيا
برايك
مرحبا بكم نعم اخبار ميونخ انا اتفق معكم
يا اخبار سيئه بالنسبه الى روسيا الغرب
يتكلم بصوت واحد ولكن هناك توجد اخبار
جيده حتى تحليل دراسه تحليليه نشرتها هذه
المنظمه خلال اعمال هذا المؤتمر هي تدل
على انه دول كثيره في افريقيا في اسيا
تريد ان تبقى في التعاون مع روسيا هذا
موجود ما بين استنتاجات مؤتمر ميونخ الان
وخبر جيد ايضا انهم يتكلمون كثيرا حول
الدبابات
وايضا معدات اخرى ولكنهم كلهم يقولون انها
لن تصل الان حتى سيد سونا كرئيس الوزراء
البريطاني وسئل امتى حتصل هذه الدبابات
حتى احد
ساله بالسخريه انه هل هي ستصل بعد ما
تنتهي هذه المواجهه فهذا السؤال له اساس
لانه دول الغرب لا تستعجل كثيرا كما يبدو
ما الذي تستبطنه برايك تصريحات السيده
فيكتوريا من ان القرم هدف مشروع للقوات
الاوكرانيه ولواشنطن والي ماذا هذا خطير
جدا بالنسبه الى روسيا
وخطير لانه هو استفزاز
فيكتوريا تعرف جيد جدا
الاجواء وتعرف طبيعه رئيس بوتين وتعرف
تماما هي انه هذه التصريحات غير مقبوله
ولكنها تصرح هذا الشيء السؤال لماذا يبدو
انه هم يريدون ان يستمروا في استفزازات
لروسيا وهذا خطير لانهم ما زالوا ينظرون
لهذه المواجهه كان نوع من المصيد امام
رئيس بوكين
بالحقيقه مثل هذه التصريحات هي ستثير
حفيظه رئيس بوتين بلا شك اولا الخارجيه
الروسيه قد ردت على هذه التصريحات الان
سيد ماتريبيس كوفا رد عليها هذا الامر غير
مقبول وروسيا لن تتخلى عن شبه جزيره القرن
كل هذه الاجواء والمواقف التصعيديه تؤشر
باننا ذاهبون الى مرحله الى مزيد من
التصعيد كمن ونوعا في المرحله المقبله
خصوصا واننا عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب هل
توافقين على ذلك
صحيح نحن امام التصعيد لانه مثلا هم
يتكلمون حول د
بابات
الى اوكرانيا في شهر ايار او حتى في نهايه
شهر ابريل هذا يعني انه لدى روسيا وقد ضيق
لكي تقوم
بالمزيد من الانجازات على الارض وهذا ما
يحدث الان ولكن ببطء شديد علينا ان نعترف
بهذا الشيء
وبالنسبه للرد الروسي على نتائج مؤتمر
ميونخ وعلى تصريحات سياسيين امريكان
فالرد سنسمعه في يوم الثلاثاء في سنه عشره
عندما سيلقي رئيس بوتين الكلمه امام مجلس
الشيوخ وانا اتساءل لماذا مجلس الشيوخ
الان اعلن بان هناك ستكون جلسه طارئه يوم
ثاني بعد هذه الكلمه من اجل ماذا وماذا
سيصرح رئيس بوتين لكي يتطلب هذا الشيء
انعقاد جلسي طارق في يوم الثالث من هذه
الكلمه طيب يعني منذ شهرين والاعلام
الغربي والامريكي يضج بالكلام
والسيناريوهات عن الهجوم الواسع النقاط
النطاق الذي ستشنه القوات الروسيه على في
اوكرانيا مع الذكرى الاولى لبدء الحرب
وهنا يمكن يعني عطف هذه الجلسه
بعشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب هل ترين فعلا
انه في سيناريو من هذا القبيل هجوم واسع
ام روسي واسع النطاق ام لا هذه ان صح
التعبير حرب نفسيه اوروباغاندا غربيه
انا من زمان صراحه انتظر هجوم واسع من قبل
روسيا في اوكرانيا ومن عده اتجاهات حتى
انا من زمان اتكلم حول هذا الشيء ولكن هل
من الضروري ان يحدث هذا الشيء متوازيا مع
الذكرى الاولى من بدا هذه المواجهه اعتقد
ان هذا خطا على روسيا ان تتصرف بغض النظر
عن
مرور سنه او اكثر او اقل
يعني المهله زمنيه هون ليست مهمه على
روسيا عم تحضر نفسها لهذا الهجوم كما يبدو
لي حتى الان
روسيا غير مستعده لهذا الشيء
من موسكو المستشار السياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه يلينا سوبولينا شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
الى شان اخر اعتبرت الخارجيه الروسيه
الغارات الاسرائيليه على دمشق انتهاكا
للقانون الدولي في منفذ وكاله الانباء
الايرانيه سقوطها قتلى في الضربه
الاسرائيليه على دمشق وريفها بسوريا واكل
واكلت وكاله ايرنا عدم وقوع اضرار في مجمع
او المدرسه الايرانيه في دمشق وقالت ارنا
ان الهجوم الاسرائيليه على دمشق نفذ على
مرحلتين الاولى في دمشق والثاني في
السويداء واضافت ان الصاروخ الاسرائيلي
سقط في نفس الموقع الذي قتل في عماد مغنيه
في دمشق
تصاعد ملحوظ للضربات الاسرائيليه على
اهداف في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
استهداف صاروخي تخترق به اسرائيل الاجواء
السوريه بهدف الوصول لمواقع ومنشات وعناصر
تابعه لايران الاستهداف الثاني خلال العام
الجاري هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي طار كفر سوسه
الحي السكني في دمشق وراحه ضحيته 15 شخصا
وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان تلك
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه استهدفت مواقع
تتمركز فيها ميليشيات ايرانيه وحزب الله
اللبناني ويعد هذا الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
الثاني خلال العام الجاري ففي الثاني من
يناير الماضي قتل سبعه عناصر جراءت ضربات
الاسرائيليه على مطار دمشق الدولي ومحيطه
وتيره الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف داخل
سوريا وثقها المرصد السوري بحوالي 32
استهدافا خلال العام الماضي وحده قامت
خلالها اسرائيل باستهداف الاراضي السوريه
سواء عبر ضربات صاروخيه او جويه اسفرت عن
اصابه وتدمير نحو 91 هدفا عسكريا
معي من مدينه البريطانيه الان مدير
المرصده السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن للحديث عن هذا الموضوع في معلومات
متضاربه اولا
معلوماتكم انتم التي وصلتم ما الذي
استهدفته هذه الغارات تحديدا في حديث عن
استهداف مسؤول كبير لم تعرف لا هويته ولا
جنسيته هل هذا الكلام صحيح ام لا
نعم نعم مساء الخير بشكل قطعي لم يستهدفه
حاره البناء الذي هو عسكري في تلك المنطقه
ولم تاتي قرارات اسرائيليه لتحترق يعني
الخرسانه او
الارضيه الاسمنتيه الى قبو هذا المبنى من
اجل قتل الحارس البناء هناك حتى اللحظه
معلومات مؤكده بان المستهدف هو شخصيه
قياديه هل قتلت الشخصيه القياديه من فيلق
القدس او من سرايا القدس لا نستطيع لا
نعلم حقيقه
حتى اللحظه لدينا المؤكدين من السوريين
سبعه هناك ثمانيه اخرين من هم الذين قتلوا
لماذا هناك يعني اخفاء لهويت هؤلاء الذين
قتلوا من النظام وتحدث عن خمسه هنا نسال
يعني الوكاله الايرانيه التي قالت لم
يستهدف المركز الثقافي من قال ان السعودي
في المركز الثقافي قلنا بجوار المركز
الثقافي وعلى العربيه يوم امس بجوار
المركز الثقافي الايراني وليس مركز ثقافي
هو مدرسه ايرانيه تستخدمها ايران في اطار
المحاوله استقطاب الشارع ايضا
يعني الكلام الاخر الذي الذي جاء عليه
الايرانيه قال هدف في السويداء وماذا عن
هدف اللي بين السيده زينب هل الهدف في تلك
المنطقه تابعه للمرصد ايضا هذه الوكاله
الايرانيه
لما تقول لو سمحت لانه في تضارب اشرت اليه
في الارقام
الحكومه السوريه فقط بمقتل خمسه بينهم
جندي انتم في المرصد تقولون 15 وربما اكثر
طب ما سر هذا التضارب
لان هناك
[موسيقى]
من الذين قدروا الاخرين الى الان هم قالوا
عسكري لدينا ثلاث ضباط واخر اذا ما كان
ضابط متطوع وطبيب والصيدلانيه وحارس
البناء يعني لدينا سبعه بينهم ثلاث ضباط
على الاقل لماذا لم يتحدث النظام عن
الضباط الثلاثه وتحدثا عن عسكري فقط الذي
هو حارس البناء المفتوح انه مدني وليس
عسكري وماذا يفعل الضباط الثلاثه في هذه
المنطقه جمي جميعهم يفترون في هذا المبنى
وهل المبنى فقط الصواريخ الاسرائيليه تقتل
الضباط فقط ولا تقتل المدنيين الموجودين
في تلك المنطقه لذلك اقول الامر يحتاج الى
الجهه التي استهدفت من استهدفت واللي جهه
التي استهدفت هل تعترف على سبيل المثال
سرايا القدس بانها هي التي استهدفت علي
يعترف القدس بانه هو الذي استهدف وهل وصل
الصاروخ الاسرائيلي الى المكان الذي كان
فيه لقاء اجتماع شخصيه لان الصاروخ
الاسرائيلي لم يقصد تلك المنطقه من اجل
قتل حارس البناء او من اجل يعني جعل
ضجه دوليه على الاستهداف كفر في وسط
العاصمه دمشق سابقا جرى استهداف في المزه
قائد سرايا القدس واليوم هذا الاستهد
اف شهدف شخصيه قياديه على اسرائيل ان
تعترف من الشخصيه القياديه التي حاولت
استهدافها في هذه البقعه من الجغرافيا
السؤال الاخير بعض المواقع تحدثت انه
للحرس الثوري ولا الفصائل ولا حتى دمشق
يمكن ان تبلع هذه الضربه بدون رد خصوصا
وان الكلفه باهظه او كبيره وان ثم ترد هل
فعلا يمكن ان نتوقع ردا ام لا يعني غار
مثل غارات الغارات السابقه ولو وجود لاي
رد مباشر
يعني لو كان هناك رد لردا ايران على قتل
قياديين بالفيلق ابو الحرس الثوري العام
الفائت وما قبل ايضا عقيل مسؤول عن تطوير
المسيرات ايضا العام الفائت لا يوجد رد
اعتقد لو كان هناك قياده في حزب الله نعم
حزب الله اقله يعني من اجل حفظ ماء الوجه
امام الجمهوريه ولكن النظام قتل كثير من
الضباط السوريين لم يرد وايران ايضا لا
تستخدم صواريخها باستهداف يا سيدي لا نريد
عمر اسرائيلي الجولان المحتال يا اخي قريب
جدا ولديكم صواريخ استهدفوا اسرائيليين
المحتل من اجل الرد على هذا القسم
الاسرائيلي على الاراضي السوريه طيب من
مدينه كوفنتري البريطانيه مدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان رمي عبد الرحمن شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه يقول ان
الوقت قد حان للوصول لحل سياسي نهائي
بسلطه مدنيه
اهلا بكم من جديد افادت اداره الكوارث
التركيه بارتفاع حصيله قتل الزلزال الى
اكثر من اربعين الف شخص واوضحت اداره
الكوارث التركيه ان عمليه البحث والانقاذ
انتهت في معظم المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال
مشيره الى انها ما زالت متواصله في قهرمان
مرعش
على المستوى الاقتصادي يجد الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان نفسه مضطرا الى اصلاح
اضرار بحوالي 79 مليار يورو وفق وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه فيما تقارب تقديرات
خبراء اخرين الكلفه ب 9 مليارات ونصف
المليار من الدولارات فقط
وتضيف رؤيه انه يتوجب على الرئيس التركي
تنفيذه تعهده لاعمار احدى عشره محافظه في
الجنوب والجنوب الشرقي من البلاد لاحقها
دمار هائل كما وعد اردوغان بمنح ملايين
الليرات التركيه للمواطنين المتضررين مع
اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه
المقرره في الرابع عشر من مايو في وقت
تواجه فيه الليره التركيه تحديا الانهيار
وفق الوكاله الدوليه
[موسيقى]
الى اسطنبول ينضم الي من هنا موفد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش عبد القادر اهلا وسهلا
بك بدايه كيف تتفاعل تداعيات هذا الزلزال
سياسيا شعبيا واخر المواقف والتصريحات
التركيه
اهلا بك طالب فعلا هناك تفاعل كبير وواسع
سياسيا وشعبيا هنا في اسطنبول جراء
تداعيات هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ما يزال
للاسف عداده مستمرا في الارتفاع ويشارك
الان الواحد والاربعين الف قتيل بحسب
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه شعبيا
دعني انقل لك تخوف كبير هنا من اسطنبول
قمت بجوله قبل حوالي ساعتين من الان في
الاحياء العتيقه لاسطنبول وهناك تخوف كبير
لسكان هذه الاحياء من ان يحصل زلزال اخر
هنا في اسطنبول في ظل التحذيرات التي
يطلقها علماء ومختصون في الزلازل وكذلك
تبعا لتحذير اطلقه عمده مدينه اسطنبول
مساء امس يطلب فيه
اصحاب المباني بضروره اجراء بصفه عاجله
الفحص الضوئي لهذه المباني التي قدرتها
بلديه اسطنبول باكثر من 100 الف مبنى يعني
حالته مترديه او مثل ما وصفته بغير متينه
ولذلك هناك قلق كبير لدى سكان هنا من ان
تحدث كارثه ربما في اسطنبول وستكون
نتائجها وخيمه جدا مثل ما يتوقع خبراء نحن
لا نتمنى ذلك طبعا لكن اليوم اصبح هذا
الموضوع اكثر جديه خصوصا بعد المصادر
افادت بانه اليوم تم اجتماع مع خبراء
للزلازل من اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه في انقره في الرئاسه التركيه
وهناك ما يجري من بحوث ودراسات ربما
لتفادي هذه الكارثه خلال السنوات القادمه
على الاقل سياسيا كما تفضلت اكيد هناك
تحديات كبيره الان تواجه الرئيس الطيب رجب
اردوغان بالتحديد خلال الانتخابات القادمه
واقتصاديا ايضا في طريقه
ويعني اساليب احتواء هذه الازمه واعاده
اعمار هذه المدن ال 11 المتضرره بشكل كبير
جدا جراء هذا الزلزال وبناء يعني مساكن
ووحدات سكنيه جديده للمتضررين هناك اخبار
تتواتر بشان تهيئه مساحات كبيره من اجل
بناء وحدات سكنيه مؤقته شاهدنا بعض
الفيديوهات لكن هذه ستكون بناءات مؤقته
مثلما
اذا كان الحديث الان كله لو سمحت اذا كان
الحديث يدور الان عن اجراءات جذريه من قبل
السلطات التركيه سواء فيما يتعلق بامور
ومعايير البناء الاسعاف الطبابه وغيرها
هنا السؤال ماذا باستطاعه السلطات فعله
الان ام لا اي اجراء ستتخذه الان سيكون
متاخرا
لكن هناك اجراءات متخذه حقيقه
واتسعت حتى خارج دوائر الحكوميه الحكومه
التركيه اليوم اعلنت عن مبادره تضامنيه
وهي تحاول توسيع هذا الفعل التضامن
للاحتواء الازمه المبادره كنت اطلعت عليها
قبل قليل وهي
اجعل بيتي بيتك
لتوسيع التضامن بين الاتراك وحتى غير
الاتراك المقيمين والذين يمتلكون عقارات
ومبان هنا في تركيا في مختلف الولايات
تكون زائده عن حاجتهم طبعا حتى يتم
تحويلها الى المتضررين هذا الزلزال سواء
بمنحها بالمجان لفترات مؤقته او بتاجيرها
باسعار معقوله جدا لهؤلاء المتضررين هذا
اسلوب من الاساليب بالاضافه الى التضامن
المؤسسات الكبيره التركيه راينا مثلا
الخطوط الجويه التركيه اعلنت قبل قليل
ايضا تمديد اسطولها الجوي الذي ينقل او
يجلي المتضررين نحو المدن الاخرى الى غايه
الفاتح من الاول من شهر مارس ادار المقبل
وهو ما قد يساعد وينقص من حجم تداعيات هذه
الكارثه بالاضافه ايضا الى قدوم اليوم
اكثر من 1000 عون وعامل في المناجم
التركيه الى المناطق المتضرره لمساعده
فيما تبقى من عمليات البحث والانقاذ رغم
توقفها في
اغلب الولايات باستثناء قهرمان مرعش
وهاتاي الاكثر تضررا من اسطنبول مفرد
العربيه عبد القادر خربوش شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد القادر على كل هذه المتابعه
هذا واشار وزير الدفاع التركيه خلصي اكار
الى عوده اكثر من عشره الاف سوري من تركيا
الى سوريا طواعيه دون الاشاره الى مزيد من
التفاصيل وذلك منذ ان ضرب زلزال عنيف
اجزاء واسعه من جنوب تركيا وشمال غربي
سوريا ووفقا لبيانات الامم المتحده تعد
تركيا اكبر الدول المستضيفه للاجئين
السوريين في العالم وفقا لبيانات الامم
المتحده
وبالتزامن مع وصول اربعه عشره شاحنه محمله
بالخيام للمشردين السوريين جراء الزلزال
شمال سوريا دعت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود الى
زياده المساعدات الانسانيه الى المنطقه
المنكوبه بشكل عاجل وحذر رئيس بعثه
المنظمه الى سوريا حكيم خالدي في بيان من
ان مخزون الطوارئ لدى المنظمه انتهى خلال
ثلاثه ايام لافتا الى عدم ملاحظته اي دعم
من الخارج واصفا كميات المساعدات التي تصل
الى المشردين بالضئيله وتاتي دعوه المنظمه
في ظل حاله غضب واسع اثارها تاخر وصول
الاغاثه الى المناطق الخارجه عن سيطره
دمشق خاصه ما لفتت اليه المنظمه في بيانها
من ان الامدادات الحاليه لا تنسجم حتى مع
حجم ما كانت عليه قبل وقوع الزلزال وفق
المنظمه
هذا هو يقطن في المناطق الخارجه عن سيطره
دمشق شمال غرب سوريا والتي طالها الزلزال
اكثر من اربعه ملايين نسمه نصفهم من
النازحين فيما يعتمد تسعون في المئه منهم
على المساعدات الانسانيه
وبعد وقوع الزلزال تاخرت مساعدات الامم
المتحده بالدخول الى المنطقه اربعه ايام
ولم تصل سوى كميات محدوده منها وتدخل
مساعدات الامم المتحده الى تلك المناطق
عبر معبر باب الهوى نقطه العبور الوحيده
التي يشملها قرار مجلس الامن لكن بامكاني
منظمات انسانيه اخرى ان تستخدم معابر اخرى
على غرار قافله اطباء بلا حدود عبر معبر
الحمام في منطقه عفرين فيما اعلنت الامم
المتحده في الثالث عشر من فبراير انها
حصلت على موافقه دمشق لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه عبر معبري باب السلامه والراعي
الحدوديين مع تركيا لمده ثلاثه اشهر
معي من ريف ادلب الصحفي محمد الاشقر محمد
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد من عندك واخر
ما وصل من مساعدات وكيف يتم توزيعها وهل
الامور تتم بدون عوائق امناء العوائق ما
زالت قائمه
نعم يعني في الحقيقه تستمر المعاناه هنا
في ريف ادلب يعني وخصوصا في مراكز الايواء
المنشاه والمستحدثه في المنطقه طبعا
المتضررون ان جون الى حد هذه اللحظه
يعانون من اوضاع ماساويه خصوصا ان هناك
نقص في مواد التدفئه ونحن في فصل الشتاء
عداك عن نقص
المواد الطبيه في عموم
المنطقه طبعا ان تحدثنا عن المساعدات
الامميه التي دخلت ووصلت الى حد هذه
اللحظه الى ريف ادلب فنحن نتحدث عن مجموع
شاحنات وصل عددهم الى 175 شاحنه حيث دخلت
اخر قافله مساعدات امميه يوم امس عندما
دخلت 14 شاحنه محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه
شاحنتان محملتان بالمستلزمات الطبيه
والمستهلكات الطبيه الادويه البشريه
والاثني عشر شاحنه المتبقيه محمله
بمستلزمات الخيام طبعا حجم المساعدات التي
وصلت الى الى المنطقه الى عموم منطقه شمال
غرب سوريا بحد وصف العاملين في المجال
الانساني فهي لا تسد الى جزء بسيط من
حاجه المنطقه لهذه المساعدات خصوصا ان
اعداد المتضررين قدرت بالالاف ولا يوجد
الى حد هذه اللحظه احصائيا نهائيه حول
اعدادهم طبعا بحسب ما صرح لنا مازن علوش
مدير مكتب العلاقات العامه سابقا قال ان
هذه المساعدات التي تدخل عن طريق معبر باب
الهوى وهنا اتحدث عن المساعدات الامميه
اغلبها تحمل سلا الاغاثيه
ندرت فيها الخيام ندرت فيها المساعدات
المخصصه للاستجابه
وهنا اتحدث عن المعدات الثقيله تحدث عن
الاجهزه المتطوره اتحدث عن الاجهزه الطبيه
اللازمه
للتجاوب وتنفيذ اغاثه المتضررين من هذه
الكارثه طبعا عدد الخيام الذي دخل الى حد
هذه اللحظه عبر جميع المنافذ الحدوديه
سواء وعندنا طريق مختلف الجمعيات
الانسانيه او حتى المنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه او حتى عن الفرق التطوعيه هي لا
تكفي لايواء جميع المتضررين مازلنا نشاهد
في بعض مراكز الايواء اكثر من عائله تقطن
خيمه واحده وهناك مراكز ايواء الى حد هذه
اللحظه يفصل فيها الرجال عن النساء
لاستيعاب اكبر عدد ممكن من المتضررين طيب
محمد وفق متابعتك والمعلومات التي تصلك
انتهت عمليات الانقاذ تماما والان الجهد
يتركز فقط على الايواء والاغاثه ام لا ما
زالت تسجل بعض محاولات وعمليات الانقاذ في
ريف ادلب
نعم يعني في الحقيقه لا يزال في بعض
المناطق فرق الدفاع المدني منتشره في محيط
المباني الممسوحه الى حد هذه اللحظه تنتظر
احتماليه الابلاغ عن وجود ضحايا تحت انقاض
مبنى ما ولكن جميع الجهود الان مركزه على
انقاذ او ايواء ومساعده واغاثه المتضررين
المنتشرين سواء كان في مراكز الايواء
المؤقته
المستحدثه او حتى في المخيمات المستحدثه
او المنشاه سابقا جميع الجهود الان تتركز
على على اغاثه هؤلاء المتضررين خصوصا ان
اغلب المخيمات المستحدثه والمنشاه قديما
تفتقر لادنى مقومات الحياه
المخيمات المستحدثه حديثا تفتقر لشبكات
الصرف الصحي تفتقر لشبكات المياه المياه
الشرب تفتقر لدورات المياه تفترق تفتقر
بالفعل تفتقر يعني ادنى مقومات الحياه من
ريف ادلبه الصحفي محمد الاشقر شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المتابعه محمد
وقعت الحكومه السودانيه وحركات مسلحه على
صيغه محدثه لتنفيذ اتفاق جوبا للسلام
بحضور رئيس المجلس الانتقالي عبد الفتاح
البرهان ورئيس جنوب السودان سيلفا كير
ميردد وفي كلمه الله خلال حفل التوقيع قال
البرهان ان حكومه البلاد ملتزمه بالعمل
على تطبيق الصيغه المحدثه لاتفاق جوبا حتى
يتحقق السلام في ربوع البلاد
ونحن على قناعه بان المصفوفه الجديده
ستشكل دافعا قويا لتنفيذ ما تبقى من بنود
الاتفاقيه صغن الله وسدد جميع للايفاء
بالالتزامات والمطلوبات
قبل ان اغادر اريد ان اذكر
من جانبه جدد نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه محمد دقلوق وصفه اجراءات الخمس
والعشرين من اكتوبر بانها انقلاب مشيرا
الى انه حان الوقت للوصول لحل سياسي نهائي
بسلطه مدنيه في السودان
حينما رايت شباب
وشابات ثوره ديسمبر المجيده لم اتردد في
الوقوف في صفهم ضد الظلم النظام البائد
واستبداده وفساده
رايت ان اشاركهم في رغبتهم في التغيير الى
الافضل وبناء السودان
حاولت ما استطعته
فصيبت حينها واخطات احيانا
واخرها خطا انقلاب 25 اكتوبر الان اتفاق
السياسي الايطالي هو مخرج بلادنا من
الازمه الراهنه وانه هو الاساس
الوحيد للحل السياسي المنصف
قال مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه في افغانستان ان التقييمات في
البلاد تشير الى ان سته وخمسين في المئه
من الاسر الافغانيه تعيش في ملاجئ مدمره
جزئيا وان 18% يعيشون في ملاجئ مدمره بشكل
كبير حيث تتزايد الحاجه الملحه لتوفير
الماوى ومواد التدفئه والملابس خلال فصل
الشتاء الحالي لتجنب تعرض الناس للمخاطر
الصحيه وذكر المكتب ان الوضع الحالي يتطلب
30 مليون دولار لتوفير الملاجئ والماوى في
فصل الشتاء خلال الربع الاول من عام 20 23
على صعيد اخر التقى زعيم وحركه طالبان
بمجموعه من الحكام والمسؤولين العسكريين
في عدد من الولايات الشماليه والغربيه
لافغانستان
وخلال اللقاء شدد زعيم وحركه طالبان بان
يتم تعيين مقاتلي الحركه في الوظائف
الحكوميه وخصوصا القوات الامنيه كونهم احد
ابرز الذين قامت عليهم طالبان في السيطره
على افغانستان حسب تعبيره وكانت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي في افغانستان قد تناقلت
صورا وتقارير عن ان بعض مقاتلي طالبان
اصبحوا يعملون في الشوارع او عاطلين عن
العمل بسبب رفض قبولهم في القوات الامنيه
لطالبات
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
130 الف اسرائيليه يتظاهرون ضد اجراءات
حكوميه وصفت بالانقلاب على القضاء
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه افاد مراسل العربيه ان نحو 130
الف اسرائيلي شاركوا في الاحتجاج الاسبوعي
الليله الماضيه في تل ابيب ضد ما يوصف
بالانقلاب على نظام القضاء في اسرائيل كما
تظاهر المئات من اليمين في القدس الغربي
حيث احتجوا ايضا على محاوله اضعاف القضاء
من قبل الحكومه وقال زعيم المعارضه ان
اسرائيل توشك على فقدان دعم الولايات
المتحده اذ انها تبدو قلقه بسبب الانقلاب
على نظام القضاء في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
زي المشاهدين لهذا المؤتمر الصحفيلي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه من تركيا
كل ما نستطيع بما في ذلك ضمان لانه بان
العقوبات لن تؤثر على المساعده الانسانيه
الى سوريا
وليس لدينا اي شكوك تحوم حول هذا الامر
نريد ان نضمن تقديم المساعدات للمحتاجين
لها في سوريا
طبعا كانت هذه كلمه مقتضبه للصحافه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتونيكن خلال تفاقده
لاثار الدمار نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا بالعوده الى المشهد السياسي الداخلي
الاسرائيلي معي من القدس الانصي مراسله
العربيه لن اهلا وسهلا
السياسي الداخلي الاسرائيلي بعد هذه
التظاهرات الحاشده والحاشده جدا وهل ستدفع
هذه التظاهرات حكومه نتنياهو للتراجع ام
لا لا شيء سيتغير حتى الساعه
يعني الوضع الداخلي حاليا في اسرائيل هو
متوتر منذ اكثر من شهر دعنا نحدد كان هناك
ايضا في الاسابيع الاخيره تحديدا ليوم
السبت مظاهرات حاشده شاهدنا اكثر من مئه
اسرائيلي الذين يعني توجهوا الى تل ابيب
والذين تظاهروا ضد هذه الحكومه وضد ايضا
قرار بالبحاوله السيطره على القضاء وجعل
الكنيسه اكبر من المحكمه العليا فعليا
يعني الشارع الاسرائيلي هو غاضب ايضا من
التنفيذ العمليات الفرديه التي قام بها
عدد من الفلسطينيين في الايام او
بالاسابيع الاخيره وايضا نشهد اليوم عصيان
مدني في القدس الشرقيه المحتله واضراب عام
شامل عدد كبير من
المناطق والاحياء منها العيساويه مخيم
شعفاط وهذا القرار ايضا خرج منه مخيم
شعفاط في القطب الشرقيه وهو المخيم الوح
الذي اتابع
للبلديه الاسرائيليه يعني نحن نتحدث عن
توتر في الاوضاع ايضا في الداخل
الاسرائيلي وايضا توتر في الضفه الغربيه
وايضا في القدس الشرقيه كان هناك يعني
اليوم اعداد كبيره من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
الذين توجهوا الى منطقه العيساويه مخيم
شعفاط كان هناك اشتباكات ايضا بين الشبان
الفلسطينيين والقوات الاسرائيليه يعني
كانت هذا او هذا او تم اعلان فعليا عن هذا
الاضراب بسبب السياسه الاسرائيليه التي
تتبعها من هذا في المساله يعني تحتاج الى
اجابه المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه في
الظاهر لا تتدخل في السياسه ولكن ما يجري
الان في الداخل الاسرائيلي خطير اين تقف
المؤسسه الامنيه مما يجري خصوصا يعني مع
اتساع دائره دائره التظاهرات والاضرابات
لم اسمع لم اسمع السؤال عفوا انا ساعود
عليك السؤال في العاده المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه لا تتدخل في السياسه او على
الاقل في الظاهر لا تتدخل في السياسه في
اسرائيل ولكن ما يجري الان خصوصا هذه
التظاهرات الحاشده مؤشر خطير بان الامور
قد تتدحرج بشكل دراماتيكي والسؤال المطروح
اين تقف المؤسسه الامنيه مما يجري يعني هل
تراقب فقط
يعني حتى الان صحيح هي تراقب فقط يعني كان
هناك مطالبه من الشباك من ان يتدخل يعني
هناك ايضا مطالبات من عدد كبير من
الاسرائيليين الذين يقولون ان على الشباك
ان يتدخلوا ان يفرض الديمقراطي واللبراليه
في اسرائيل ولكن الشباك يرد ويقول فعليا
بانه لا يستطيع ان يتدخل في هذه الامور
فحتى الان ما نشهده هو فقط مراقبه للامر
الواقع ومراقبه لهذه التظاهرات من بعيد
من القدس لانك الغاصي مراسله العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
حذرت الصين الولايات المتحده من انها
ستكون مسؤوله عن كل العواقف في حال تصعيد
الخلاف بشان ازمه المنطاد الذي تم اسقاطه
من قبل القوات الجويه الامريكيه وقالت
الخارجيه الصينيه في بيان لها انها ستقوم
بالمتابعه حتى النهايه في حال اصرار
الولايات المتحده على استغلال هذا الامر
وياتي هذا البيان بعد اجتماع بعد اجتماع
كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين
ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي على هامشي مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن
اعلنت كوريا الجنوبيه عن اجراء جيشها
تدريبات جويه مشتركه مع الولايات المتحده
تتضمن قاذفه استراتيجيه امريكيه وذلك بعد
اطلاق كوريا الشماليه لصاروخ باليستيه
عابر للقاره بعد امر مباشر من الرئيس كيم
جونغ اون دون اشعار مسبق
وفي المقابل بس التلفزيون كوريا الشماليه
الحكومي مقاطع فيديو تظهر احدث تجربه
اطلاق صاروخ باليسي عابر للقارات في
البلاد فيما ذكرت وسائل اعلام رسميه اخرى
ان الاطلاق جرى في مطار بيونج الدولي في
سونان احدى ضواحي العاصمه
نشره الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]